so if you care about environment if you
care about climate change do we really
want to be the generation that wasted
another decade not fixing this or do we
want to be the generation who said let's
be smart hi i'm ron bailey four reason
TV today we're talking with Bjorn
Lomborg who is the head of the Danish
think-tank the Copenhagen consensus
Center and the author of The Skeptical
environmentalist today's topic is how
can humanity best reduce the damage and
harm that we might suffer from manmade
global warming so first I want to ask
you a question is global warming a
problem it is a problem yes almost all
researchers are telling us this is
man-made this is a problem it's probably
not much of a problem right now but it
will certainly towards the end of the
century be a significant problem
especially in the developing world so
what is the Copenhagen climate consensus
project what is that all about it's
really a process to set priorities what
we asked is a lot of different
researchers in a lot of different fields
to come up with smart solutions to
climate so that could be anywhere from
geoengineering to black carbon to
obviously cut carbon emissions we asked
them all tell us how much is your
solution going to cost and how much good
is it going to do in the sense of how
much climate damage is it going to avoid
and then you can compare them you can
essentially say how much bang or how
much climate bang do you get for every
buck you spend and shouldn't we be
spending it our money where it does the
most good for climate first so could you
briefly tell us what it was that
happened at the Copenhagen consensus
panel we had some of the world's top
economists look at what's the smartest
thing to do on climate change the very
first proposal and the very top priority
from the panel was marine Cloud
whitening it's essentially a deer
engineering technique where you amplify
a natural process waves meet they clash
up seawater and that evaporates small
particulate of salt that basically forms
the nuclei of clouds and that basically
means the world get a little whiter and
therefore reflect sunlight it's a very
natural process it's incredibly cheap
nine billion dollars can basically save
climate
the next century now there's some
problems in there and we need to work
those out and see if they actually work
that's why we need to do research in
that the second part is to say let's
make sure we make energy especially
green energy much cheaper in the future
if green energy is cheap everybody will
want it but you can't make that
transition before it's cheap you can't
get the Chinese and the Indians on board
that is the way to fix climate change in
the long run those two in combination
means we have a way to fix climate and
50 to 100 years and we have a way to
transition our societies to non-fossil
fuel economies well let's go to the
bottom of the list and what what what
what were the things that the the expert
panel basically thought we're not
worthwhile pursuing well I think it's
very clear if you look at the list that
the carbon tax came out at the very
bottom of the list
and it was really important to say it
was not just any big carbon tax but it
was even also fairly low carbon taxes
it's a very ineffective way of spending
a lot of money and actually doing fairly
little good for the climate
it doesn't mean climate change is not a
problem it doesn't mean that this is
part of the solution perhaps in raising
revenue but it means that believing you
can cut carbon emissions is a very poor
way of enacting very little climate
benefits and hence one that's probably
not going to happen and one
unfortunately that most of the world
seem intent on failing to understand
that point and keep on saying let's cut
carbon emissions once again even though
we've failed a couple of times already
and when you say we failed you mean this
is the kind of thing that we did with
the Kyoto Protocol and what we're likely
to be doing that when the UN meets at
Copenhagen in December yes and we did
this in Rio in 1992 we promised a lot of
times to cut carbon emissions and not
lived up to it why would Copenhagen be
different so if you care about
environment if you care about climate
change do we really want to be the
generation that wasted another decade
not fixing this or do we want to be the
generation who said let's be smart let's
spend our money better
let's get projects that actually work
for the climate that have much more
efficiency and it's much more likely to
be implemented
thanks Bjorn for reason TV I'm Ron
Bailey